>>> MORE NOW, BREAKING NEWS THIS
HOUR, STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS IT
IS REDUCING STAFFING LEVELS AT
THE U.S. EMBASSY IN KIEV,
REPORTS RUSSIA IS PLANNING
SIGNIFICANT MILITARY ACTION
AGAINST UKRAINE.
RUSSIA HAS MASSED MORE THAN
100,000 TROOPS AT ITS BORDER
WITH UKRAINE DESPITE REPEATED
CONVERSATIONS WITH WESTERN
LEADERS AIMED AT EASING THE
CRISIS.
STATE DEPARTURE SAYS THEY ARE
VOLUNTARY WITH U.S. EMBASSY
STAFF AND FAMILY MEMBERS THE
FIRST TO GO, NOTE THERE, THE
FAMILY MEMBERS OF THE STAFF ARE
BEING ORDERED TO GO.
NATIONAL SECURITY CORRESPONDENT
KYLIE ATWOOD JOINS US NOW.
SO KYLIE, WHAT CAN YOU TELL US
ABOUT WHAT WAS BEHIND THIS MOVE?
>> Reporter: YEAH A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHY THE
DEPARTMENT DID THIS NOW, SENIOR
OFFICIALS JUST SPOKE ON A CALL
WITH REPORTERS TO EXPLAIN THIS
DECISION CAME OUT OF AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION.
SO IT'S BASICALLY, WHAT THEY
SAID, IS THE TOTALITY OF THE
SITUATION WITH RUSSIA CONTINUING
ITS EFFORTS TO DESTABILIZE
UKRAINE, ITS MILITARY BUILD-UP
ALONG THE BORDERS, THOSE ARE THE
FACTORS THAT WENT INTO THIS
DECISION FOR THEM TO, AS YOU
SAID, AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTURE OF
SOME U.S. GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES
AND ORDER THE DEPARTURE OF THE
FAMILIES OF THOSE U.S.
GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEES AT THE
EMBASSY IN KIEV, SO NOT
NECESSARILY A HEIGHTENED RISK
THAT THOSE U.S. PERSONNEL ARE IN
TODAY VERSUS YESTERDAY, BUT THEY
DO FEEL THAT THE TOTALITY OF THE
SITUATION MADE IT SO THAT THEY
SHOULD START ALLOWING AND THEN,
OF COURSE, TELLING SOME OF THOSE
AMERICANS TO GET OUT.
SO THAT'S, YOU KNOW, THE GIST OF
THIS HERE, BUT THERE IS ANOTHER
ASPECT OF IT WHICH IS THAT
AMERICAN VISIT ZN WHOSE ARE IN
THE COUNTRY, AND THE STATE
DEPARTMENT IS ESSENTIALLY
ENCOURAGING THEM TO LEAVE,
UNVEIL THEMSELF OF COMMERCIAL
OPTIONS, THEY WON'T SAY HOW MANY
WITH THE STATE DEPARTMENT ARE IN
UKRAINE RIGHT NOW, THEY THINK
JUST PROVIDING THAT INFORMATION
WOULDN'T BE HELPFUL AT THIS TIME
BECAUSE AMERICANS AREN'T
REQUIRED TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION BUT IT WAS REALLY
NOTEWORTHY THAT THE DEPARTMENT
WAS VERY CLEAR IN SAYING THAT
BIDEN, THE PRESIDENT, IS NOT
GOING TO BE EVACUATING U.S.
CITIZENS IF RUSSIA INVADES
UKRAINE.
SO IF THEY WANT TO LEAVE THE
COUNTRY, THOSE AMERICAN WHOSE
ARE THERE ON THEIR OWN ACCORD
SHOULD START LOOKING FOR
COMMERCIAL OPTIONS NOW.
>> KYLIE ATWOOD, THANK YOU FOR
THAT, BRINGING BACK DEMOCRAT
CONGRESSMAN ELAINE LURIA.
SO WE JUST HEARD KYLIE ATWOOD
BREAK DOWN WHAT IS BEHIND THIS,
SAYING THEY'LL DO IT WITH AN
ABUNDANCE OF CAUTION.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT.
>> WELL, I THINK THERE ARE
OBVIOUSLY RISING TENSIONS.
WE'VE BEEN ALL IN ON
NEGOTIATIONS TO INTEND TO GET
RUSSIA TO BACK DOWN WITH 100,000
TROOPS ON THE BORDER AND I THINK
WE ARE SEEKING PRESSURE ON
RUSSIA TO TRY TO CONVINCE THEM
AND IT'S NOT IN THE BENEFIT TO
INVADE UKRAINE, BUT, YOU KNOW,
THOSE CIVILIANS WHO WERE AT
EMBASSY AND U.S. CIVILIANS
WITHIN UKRAINE, IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT HAS A PLAN TO HELP
THOSE PEOPLE GET TO SAFETY AND I
ACTUALLY WROTE A LETTER THIS
WEEK WITH ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES
TO THE ADMINISTRATION SAYING,
YOU KNOW, WHAT IS THE PLAN?
WE HAVE HAD BRIEFINGS AS
CONGRESS FROM DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE AND I REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE THERE IS A GOOD SOLID
PLAN TO BE ABLE TO REACT AND GET
THOSE AMERICANS OUT IF WE HAVE,
YOU KNOW, RUSSIA DOES DECIDE TO
TAKE THIS DRASTIC MEASURE.
>> WE KEEP HEARING U.S.
OFFICIALS SAY THAT THEY ARE
READY TO IMPOSE SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES IF RUSSIA MOVES IN.
BUT WE HAVE SEEN ENOUGH TICK IN
ACTIVITY FROM THE U.S. IN TERMS
OF GIVING AID TO UKRAINE, NOW
YOU HAVE THIS MOVE AT THE
EMBASSY THERE IN UKRAINE.
DO YOU THINK WE COULD SEE A
CHANGE IN THE U.S. RESPONSE TO
RUSSIA NOW THAT THEY'VE SCALED
BACK PERSONNEL AT THEIR EMBASSY
IN UKRAINE?
>> WELL, WHAT I SAY IS THAT WE
NEED TO PROVIDE THE MAXIMUM
SECURITY ASSISTANCE AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE.
WE DID 60 MILLION, AUTHORIZED
ANOTHER 200 MILLION, SEE MORE
SHIPMENT OF DEFENSIVE WEAPONS
DELIVERED TO UKRAINE AS WE
SPEAK, THAT HAPPENED TODAY, AND
ALSO AWARE THAT THERE'S
REPORTING FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION VERY RECENTLY
THAT THE UNITED STATES IS
REINFORCING ITS NUMBER OF TROOPS
WITHIN NATO, IN THE AREAS OF
EASTERN EUROPE AND NEAR UKRAINE,
AND REALLY, THE STICK, YOU KNOW,
IF YOU'RE GOING TO TALK ABOUT A
CARROT ON A STICK, WE'VE BEEN
VERY CLEAR THAT THERE WILL BE
SEVERE CONSEQUENCES FROM THE
U.S. AND U.S. ALLIES IF RUSSIA
DOES DECIDE TO INVADE UKRAINE
AND I THINK THIS COULD COME IN
THE FORM OF VERY, VERY DRACONIAN
SANCTIONS AND I THINK THAT, YOU
KNOW, THERE'S ALSO THE CONCERN
ABOUT THE PIPELINE IN GERMANY
AND THE IMPACTS THAT COULD HAVE
ON RUSSIA AS WELL.
>> WE'RE ALSO LEARNING THAT
CHINA SENT 39 WAR PLANES INTO
TAIWAN'S AIR DEFENSE ZONE ON
SUNDAY.
DO YOU THINK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN DOING
ENOUGH WITH THE ESCALATING
TENSION WITH CHINA?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, THIS IS AN
ISSUE I FOLLOW VERY CLOSELY,
SPENT 20 YEARS IN THE NAVY
MYSELF, HAD NUMEROUS
OPPORTUNITIES TO DEPLOY TO
WESTERN PACIFIC.
WHAT I WOULD SAY IS EVERY SINGLE
DAY IS TRULY A GRAY ZONE
CONFLICT IN THE PACIFIC AND FROM
MY OPINION, I THINK WE'RE NOT
DOING ENOUGH.
WE NEED TO BE BUILDING OUR NAVY,
DEPLOY FORCES DIFFERENTLY, TRULY
HAVE A DETERRENT IN THE REGION
AND I THINK THE CURRENT U.S.
POLICY OF STRATEGIC AMBIGUITY IS
NOT ENOUGH.
I TH